Speaker 1: So it does seem as though we're
getting to the end stage of Donald Trump's
complete and total derangement over the 2020
election.
We are just, what, eight weeks, seven and
a half weeks roughly from the 2022 midterms.
And Donald Trump is now demanding that he
be made the president immediately or that
a new 2020 presidential election be held.
This is obviously something only somebody
who is very sick could even think of demanding.
Donald Trump, of course, posting this to his
platform, Truth, Social Trust Central, a platform
which is having its fair share of trouble,
which we will get to in a moment.
Donald Trump posting yesterday and this is
this is bottom of the barrel stuff, guys,
quote So now it comes out conclusively that
the FBI buried the Hunter Biden laptop story
before the election, knowing that if they
didn't, Trump would have easily won the 2020
presidential election.
This is massive fraud and election interference
at a level never seen before in our capital
c country.
Remedy declare the rightful winner.
Trump means make me president or and this
would be the minimal solution.
Declare the 2020 election irreparably compromised
and have a new capital E election immediately.
He seems to be saying that the FBI, not helping
him as he sees it, is some kind of election
fraud, tampering or interference.
And by the way, the FBI sort of did tip the
scales for Trump in the first election that
he won.
I mean, think back to 2016.
James Comey already did a press conference
about the Hillary email stuff.
It was a closed subject.
And then right before the election, for reasons
that are still not clear, James Comey comes
out and does another press conference about
that very same investigation, even though
there were not charges forthcoming and Hillary
Clinton was not going to be charged with anything.
That is the reality of the situation.
And think how I we're roughly it's funny,
we're about 666 days since the presidential
election of 2020.
It's just a coincidence.
And I don't know if that's tomorrow or the
next day.
We're roughly it will be soon, 666 days since
the 2020 presidential election.
And Donald Trump wants to either be reinstated
or wants a brand new election.
It says likely that Mike Pillow or Eric Trump
are going to be put in the Oval Office in
the next two years.
As it is, Trump is going to.
Speaker 2: Over 54 countries have now been
taken by the machines.
Speaker 1: Exactly.
Remember this op ed from November of 2020?
It was written by Mick Mulvaney.
Remember Mick Mulvaney, who for a while was
Donald Trump's chief of staff?
And the subject was, if he loses, Trump will
concede gracefully.
He'll fight hard to make sure the results
are fair, and in the end, he'll accept the
result, whatever it is.
That was Mick Mulvaney writing in November
of 2020, specifically November 7th of 2020.
How humiliating is this?
How long is it going to go?
And I know that we all joked around we had
sort of a good time, even though it was like
laughing to avoid crying, saying when it was
February of 2021, when it was April of 2021,
we joked around and we said, Wow, how long
are they going to keep doing this?
How are they going to go all the way up to
the 2022 midterms talking about reinstatement?
And Trump continues to talk about it and Mike
Pillow continues to talk about it.
And other hangers on continue to talk about
reinstatement.
We are now getting to the November 22 midterms.
The question now is, are they going to keep
talking about reinstatement beyond the November
22 midterm, which would be just another level
altogether?
It is wacky, wacky stuff.
And the next layer of trouble is that the
platform on which Donald Trump is publishing
these deranged tirades is in very serious
trouble.
Let's talk about that next